but once dr fauci thought he was off
camera the mask came off
literally you want to see hypocrisy in
action look at this
here's dr fauci sitting within six feet
of other people to
mostly empty stadium without wearing his
mask
well he was immediately called on this
but rather than copying to it and being
honest
he acted like so many people in power do
and scorned anyone criticizing him watch
i think this is sort of mischievous with
this thing going around
i had my mask around my chin i had taken
it down
i was totally dehydrated and i was
drinking water
trying to re rehydrate myself
and by the way i was negative coveted
literally the day before
so i guess people want to make a bing of
that i wear a mask all the time
when i'm outside to pull it down to take
some sips of water and put it back up
again
i guess if people want to make something
about that they can
oh if people want to make a thing of it
if people want to make a fetish of masks
people are worried about kovid lighten
up america oh wait no i'm sorry you're
dr anthony fauci
you're one of the reasons our economy is
ground to a halt you're one of the
reasons that people are
as unhappy as they've ever been were you
just four minutes ago lecturing us about
how we're immoral if we don't wear a
mask but when you do it it's
totally cool because you've got good
excuses you were thirsty
no you were laughing with your friends
we bet that doctor fought you won't have
to pay the
thousand dollar fine that the district
of columbia is now imposing on citizens
who don't wear masks in public
here's the mayor of washington air
quotes around that word muriel bowser
announcing the policy watch i am also
today signing a new mayor's order on
mask
and basically what it says is if you
leave home
you should wear a mask this means if
you're waiting for a bus
um you must have on a mask if you are
ordering food at a restaurant
you must have on a mask if you're
sitting in a cubicle in an open
office you must have on a mask
until the day joe biden wins the
presidential election
you mr mrs america must wear masks
unless of course
you're the people who wrote the mask
ordinance in dc the politicians
they exempted themselves oh
because they've suspended the rules of
science because they're in power and
you're not so shut up and obey until
biden wins
that's the rule mass for thee but not
for me